hey it's the ktna and this is our song
[Music]
MBD it's been about 27 hours since my
last manal
breakdown that's a
record I guess for right
now and I have been buing my head
against the wall for at least a week
now it's filled with no
things and yet it weighs me down it's
been about 27 hours since my last mental
breakdown and that's a
record I guess for right
now I have been Bing my head against the
wall for Le to weat now it's filled with
no
things and yeah it weighs me down it's
been about 27 37 47 57 I don't know I
can't count anymore
[Music]
no I don't know if we're going fast or
if we're going slow what I do know is my
state of mind a big BL
more I don't know if reality is starving
in show but if the lights came down they
CH you why the hell took so long listen
I don't know if we're going F we're
going slow but what I do know is my
state of Minds a big block M old and I
don't know if reality is a starving in
an alien show but if the lights be down
it shows me now and what the hell took
so long it's been about 27 hours since
my last mental break
down and that's a
record yeah I guess for right
now and I'll be been Bing my at so all
for at least a week now it's filled with
no
things and yeah it weighs me down it's
been about 27 hours since my last mental
breakdown and that's a
record yeah I guess for right
now and I have been Bing my head against
the wall for at least a week
now it's filled with nor
th and yeah he waits me
down
oo
[Music]
yeah
wo